your real work is
to figure out where your power base is
i tell those students you know you may
have to take a job or two
you got you got to eat but never give up
searching for the job that's your
passion try to find the job
that you would have if you were
independently rich computers still can't
read
they they cannot take a book of
information
and say pass an ap test on that book
and that's a solvable problem wanna be
happy
live a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you're
capable of more
you have michael jordan level talent at
something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn how billionaires think to
get some success
advice from the top enjoy
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one believe with elon musk
tell me what was the turning point from
you know talking with the russians and
then deciding okay
i'm going to do this i'm going to set up
a company what was that turning point
for you
well um i i guess i
i had i came to conclusion that um my
initial premise was was wrong
uh that in fact the um
there's there's a great deal of will uh
you know
that there's there's not such a shortage
but people don't think there's a way
and and that if people thought there was
there was a way or do something that
wouldn't
break the federal budget um then then
people
would support it which in retrospect i
think is actually
kind of obvious because um the
the united states is a distillation of
the human spirit of exploration
people came here from other places um i
mean it's
you know there's no nation there's no i
mean there's no nation that that's more
a nation of explorers in the united
united states but but people need to
believe that it's possible
and it's that it's not you know it's
they're not going to give up like health
care or something important
you know it's got to be that that that's
important so
so i thought okay well then it's not a
question of well it's
it's a question of showing that there's
a way um and
and the and i started reading quite a
bit about rockets to try to understand
why they're
so freaking expensive rule number two
work on yourself with oprah winfrey
i say to the my girls all of the time
that your real work is
to figure out where your power base is
and to work on the alignment of
your personality your
gifts that you have to give with the
real reason why you're here
that's that's the number one thing you
have to do
is to work on yourself and to fill
your self up and keep
your cup full keep yourself full now i
used to be afraid of that
i used to be afraid particularly from
people who say oh she said she's so full
of hassan
she's so close herself and now i
embrace it i i consider it a compliment
that i am full of myself
because you only when you're full i'm
full i'm overflowing my cup run is over
i have so much i have so much to offer
and so much to give
and i am not afraid of honoring
myself you know it's miraculous when you
think about it
rule number three find your passion with
warren buffett
you're lucky in life if you can find
your passion i tell the students you
know what
you may have to take a job or two you
got to eat
but never give up searching for the job
that's your passion
try to find the job that you would have
if you were independently rich
that's the job i have and when you find
that job the job that causes you
to be excited every day and forget about
the pain
and where you associate with people you
love doing what you love it doesn't get
any better than that my partner charlie
is 89
and we were talking about that this
weekend you know i'm 82 he's 89.
we do what we love every day with people
we love you know and they seem to like
us okay so
you know it how can it be any better and
just
cost of living does not equate the
standard of living and the standard of
living is you know
achieving what you want to achieve
working with people that you love and
you don't need that much money aside i
love to ride around in a private point i
will
totally acknowledge that leave it
leaving that out you know i basically
you know leaving out taxes and charity
and things like that i can live
easily live on a hundred thousand
dollars a year and and it
and i wouldn't live i wouldn't live
better if i had eight houses
if i hadn't you know a 400 foot yacht or
anything of the sort i've
i've been on 400-foot yachts and i've
been a lot of fancy houses
but i'm in a house that i bought 55
years ago
it's warm in the winter it's cool in the
summer
it has everything i wanted plus it has
all kinds of good memories you know
my kids have good thoughts about it i
can't imagine
living any better i paid thirty one
thousand five hundred dollars for it i
could pay 31 million
for a house and and it wouldn't it
wouldn't do for me what this present
house does
rule number four be vision driven with
jack ma
first i i tried making sure
that this company is a vision driven
strategy company it's a vision driven
company
i hate that alibaba i appeal and every
day we worry about next quarter the
quarter after next
and this is no good this is i hate about
that
i i'm happy to be on the ball
uh join some board many years ago some
big multinational companies are joined
there
and when they make decisions they they
hate they worry about make a decision
for the future everybody
only care for next quarter and they buy
company
merge company just for next quarter so i
hate that
so i say the day when we ipo we have to
be making sure
that this company in next 84 years
should always be a vision driven company
also if you want to have unstoppable
confidence and learn from billionaires
check out my 254 series they're free
the links are joined on the description
below your number one
job is to become more of yourself
starting companies like staring into
your bus and eating glass
ideas don't come out fully formed
they only become clear as you work on
them
you just have to get started rule number
five
solve problems with bill gates my
question to you is
if you suddenly found yourself to be say
a sophomore in college
at harvard what do you think you would
uh study and how do you think you'd
spend your time engaging activities
well the thing that you're likely to be
world class at
is whatever you obsessed over from say
age 12
to 18. you know in my case it was
writing software
uh where i would think i was good and
then i would meet somebody who would
tell me i wasn't and
i would look at their code and i went
through four sort of comeuppances
of oh that's what a really good
programmer looks like and part of the
reason i worship digital equipment was
eventually it was a couple of their very
best programmers
who came and shared with me how they
thought about how they did thing and i
had studied their code and
uh and that and there there were several
people who were
so key to my doing that so today
i would go into you know software which
today that means going into artificial
intelligence
uh you know computers still can't read
they they cannot take a book of
information
and say pass an ap test on that book
and that's a solvable problem but it's a
knowledge representation problem
and you know i've always wanted to solve
that problem uh i'm jealous
that maybe one of you gets to work on
that
i'm you know unlikely to go back and be
hands on in that
in that way but it's the juiciest
problem ever i've thought about it for a
long time uh
so i would go into ai rule number six be
right
a lot with jeff bezos amazon has 14
leadership principles and this is the
one that
often catches people a little by
surprise
because one of our leadership principles
is that good leaders are right a lot
and um it sounds kind of like well
great but is there some way that i can
practice
being right a lot and you're not gonna
do read all the time but i do think you
with practice you can be right more
often and i've observed people who are
right a lot and i notice a few things
about them
the first is that people who are right a
lot they listen a lot
and people who are right a lot change
their mind a lot
and people who write a lot they seek to
disconfirm their most profoundly held
convictions which is very unnatural for
humans
so humans mostly as we go about life
we're very selective in the evidence
that we let
seep into us and we like to observe the
evidence that confirms
our pre-existing beliefs and people who
write a lot work very hard to do that
unnatural thing
of trying to disconfirm their beliefs
and rule number seven the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is focus on scaling with mark zuckerberg
do you remember how much your first
server cost you said oh yeah no 85
85 yeah no i and i remember that because
um that was the gating factor for us
launching new schools i
i mean we had this philosophy from the
very beginning that we didn't want to be
this project it wasn't even a company at
the very beginning but we didn't want
to be burning a lot of money right we
weren't planning on raising a lot of
money we didn't want to be
one of these things that raised a bunch
of money and you know was losing a bunch
of money and then decided that we'd
somehow pull it through at the end and
um so you know so 85 for the first
server put ads on the site and
the the ads at the beginning were uh we
just were running some kind of ad
network and
you remember what the first ad was um no
i don't um i don't know how did you get
ads
um this was eduardo's job was i mean
with your ad sales
yeah he basically like he was
responsible for making sure that we had
enough money to keep things running in
the beginning
and um you know but basically i mean so
it was the server was 85
and you know dustin and i basically
worked on kind of efficiency and making
sure that we can fit more schools onto
each server
um and um and eduardo worked on selling
more ads or making a deal so that we can
get
an ad network so that way we can we can
make more money but then whenever we had
more money we
rented another 85 a month server and we
kind of went from there
and um i don't know just it's just an
interesting way of seeing you never
spent money you didn't have in the
beginning
not in the beginning no and then i mean
even that was the constraint on your
growth rate how many new 85 dollars you
could get yeah and i mean it was
actually good because
i i mean you know sometimes it's really
nice to have the time to
get your product to be awesome and deal
with scaling problems and one of the
things that was interesting was um
you know at the time i don't know how
many people remember this but i mean
friendster was the service that had
massive scaling problems
yeah you know the idea was they were
they grew quickly and it was really hard
for them to scale and
um you know the fact that we could kind
of go college by college and
and kind of optimize the service and
make it more efficient and offer new
features but make sure that they worked
um i think was really key i mean we're
talking about people who had never built
a company before we never built any
large-scale software
or anything so having that period where
we could just bake it
and you know people these days like to
talk about how these services grow super
quickly
then facebook did grow quickly but i
think it took a year for us to get a
million users and we thought that that
was incredibly fast but
um and and i think it is but it wasn't
as quick as a lot of things grow today
and i think actually having that
time to bake it was really valuable for
us now i've got a really special bonus
clip that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and what are you going
to do to take action on it this week
when you write down
what day what time and what place you're
going to take action on something you
have a 91
chance of following through versus just
35
if you got motivated but never wrote
down a plan
and when you share your plan and have
public accountability it raises your
chances of following through
even higher so that's what i want to do
today for you guys
you watch this video what was your
single biggest takeaway and what is your
plan
to take action on it this week let me
know put it down
in the comments below there's a shark
king tank company from last season
called mush
right cool stuff it's like this um
oatmeal that they package it's fresh
dried oatmeal
that they package with a little spoon
and you it has to be refrigerated but
you just grab it and go
and the the response was great from the
show
and now like i just saw their numbers
they went from 50 000 in sales to 100
000 to 125 000 in three straight months
it's not scale but they're growing right
and they're all of a sudden like
okay we got to go raise money and we got
to do yada yada
right scale is hard not just because of
the economic cost
but also because of the people cost and
the mind share cost
it's hard when you're dealing with a
major company and in particular if
you're dealing with a big company like a
walmart
or costco or whatever because you only
get one shot of those guys
and so like i told mush with whole foods
they're interested i'm like you're not
ready you're not ready
you have got to you got to crawl before
you ball
you know and
and and and so i told him
it's going to be painful not to go after
that big customer
but think about what happens if you go
after it
and a it's going to take capital you
don't have and you're going to borrow it
or b it doesn't work out and they return
it all then all of a sudden you're out
of business
and so you're right that you need
capital to scale
but you also need the confidence
that you can scale and that you can keep
your customers happy
and so i always tell people get to the
point
where you have you you've taken care of
the customers that you can take care of
once you can demonstrate that then you
can get smart money
and you're talking from a position of
power and then you can go to the
walmarts of the world the costco's
and you may not even have to raise money
they may even provide
po leverage or po support or connect you
with a bank that does
and so i guess i guess what i'm saying
is
don't get too far ahead of yourself
because sometimes
sales can be a lot more expensive than
you think they are
and you've got to be careful i've seen
several my shark tank companies try to
get too big too fast
and it almost put them out of business
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days check the link right
here below me or if you want another
video on how billionaires think check it
out right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy them
continue to believe and i'll see you
there